foreign
that's enough of that let's go to Leslie
insane Paul what's up Leslie
hi Dr John how are you I'm fantastic how
are you
doing great thank you live life's going
okay
yeah excellent what's up how can I help
so um something I've been wrestling with
internally is wanting to break
generational curses as a first
generation immigrant but you know
feeling a lot of guilt so I had called
into the Dave Ramsey Show and it was
mostly a financial question my senior
year of high school I saved up a bunch
of money to pay cash for my first car
and because I was 17 and a minor at the
time my mom had access to my bank
account and she decided to take that
money and pay off her debt money for my
car I'm so sorry called and George and
Christina
kind of financial asset
asked you could guide me through the
emotional aspect of you know I'm in
college right now I'm studying really
hard to get a good job and like avoid
debt the phone
there's that emotional part of it
what's your what's your cultural
background
okay
is that a strongly maternal culture
uh yeah yeah actually no
no
um
oh man
here's the thing let's let's this is
hard to do and it's really probably not
the right thing to do but let's take the
cultural aspect you know what you can I
can't just tell you to scoot that over
let me just say this
um
I think in in in my Western context
taking somebody's money from them is
wrong across the board
it is in my culture too I mean I was
talking to my siblings my
oh maybe you should
well I don't want to do that I don't I
think that's that's been a problem as
though you can just take culture on and
off like a pair of sunglasses right
um but that that helps me because there
are cultures that
your kids are very much yours and so
what's what's theirs is yours and so it
would be seen as something that in my
house would I would consider stealing
you're a thief you stole from me and in
other cultures it might not be seen that
way so I want to be sensitive to that
but at the same time I want to honor
your requests to begin to
create your new life here
um as the first gen immigrant and you
get to begin to
wrestle with how do you hold on to the
Heritage parts of your heritage that you
want to keep and you want to be a part
of your life moving forward how do you
how do you grab onto these this new
Western culture that you're learning and
then really what do you have designed
for your life and it sounds like if I I
want to speak into too much but it it
sounds like what you're saying is
I have to grieve the loss of my mother
because she stole from me and I'm done
with that relationship is that fair
I don't want to be done with the
relationship because I know she adds a
lot of hurt herself but I do think that
it's wrong okay let me stop you right
there
you aren't responsible for her hurt
and her hurt doesn't give Liberty for
her to steal from you
I always always
think parents have a right to be treated
with dignity or and respect even if it's
in a dignified way in a respectful way
saying I'm never going to talk to you
again
okay or saying I the word here is
boundaries you are going to have to
learn how to create boundaries that keep
you safe keep your stuff safe and
sometimes staying safe inside of a
boundary also hurts really bad because
it's lonely and you should have your mom
as your number one fan in your life
right now and your mom took from you
and let me also add this layer
she took your money but I think she took
something bigger from you
I think what she also took from you is
your your supports like you were resting
on her and then suddenly she pulled that
that uh support out from under you does
that make sense
yeah that makes sense it's almost like
you lost your money and that's
heartbreaking and all that you had plans
for that money but it's almost
heartbreaking in like
it's like you're walking on Sand now
right like you can't get a firm firm
grasp on the ground I don't know tell me
tell me keep talking
yeah so like the financial aspect is one
thing but that it was like the
manipulation and the gaslighting that
ensued like almost
like okay well you know money comes and
goes it can be replaced but the
manipulation and gaslighting and then
also like hey Leslie Leslie make sure
you're talking into your phone okay
yeah there you go and then also trying
to build my own Financial picture but
then like knowing that I'm responsible
for someone else's at the same time is
very stressful you're not you're 18
years old
okay
now here's here's here's the deal if you
make big if you make adult decisions
Sometimes they come with adult
consequences what I mean by that
you get your own account so that your
mom can't take it anymore
which I did okay do you pay your own
tuition
I I get full ride scholarships so no I
don't pay any tuition but I mean you're
not dependent on her financially
nope not at all okay
um now you have to decide how much I you
can be around her
emotionally physically financially
before you become somebody that you do
not want to become
you become somebody who is snippy who
has to hide things who can't tell the
truth who whatever because it's not safe
see what I'm saying
yeah I understand and this is going to
be really hard because
you're 18 years old and your mom should
be your number one cheerleader and
instead your mom's leading the charge of
making it difficult for you to find your
footing as you grow into adulthood
yeah have you grieved that have you sat
down and just wept
or have you just been angry
yeah I remember one time I just had a
total emotional breakdown that was just
like sobbing like crying hysterically to
the point where like she could hear me
all the way upstairs and then she came
in my room it's like oh my gosh why are
you crying and you didn't even tell me
um I can't believe that I'm not the
first person you would run to and I
didn't do anything wrong
um by taking your money I didn't do
anything wrong so I don't understand why
you're crying so that was that was the
response I got and you know that's
manipulative right
yes I I understand okay and
there's something deeper than the
manipulation you know that that's your
mother severing the relationship and
that hurts
it's really easy to stop at the act that
makes us enraged or scared but beneath
that
this the most core relationship you have
is with your mom
and she told you through her actions
this relationship is over now it is
something different
and quite honestly you've probably known
that for a long time is that fair
I guess this type of manipulation and
dishonesty and thievery doesn't just
happen once
okay okay
so the real question is what are you
gonna do now
and then you know like obviously I
morally it does not feel right to me to
leave your parents destitute for
retirement but I also understand that my
finances have to come first so I don't
know I guess I'm struggling internally
with finding like the right balance is
it you that's leaving them destitute or
is it your mom choosing to not work and
your dad choosing to not work
are they unable
she does work but she has a bunch of
debt that she's making no effort to pay
off
how is an 18 year old kid going to be
more responsible for her adult mother's
life than her adult Mother
it's
you're not you not only are you not
being invited in to be a part of this
solution
um you're being excluded from this
right you're um
uh it's a very parasitic relationship
and we're like you are starving you
can't continue doing that because but
because it's such an easy job she
doesn't want to quit and do something
that
participle
has she asked you to come help pay her
bills
in fact she's like 45 and she's like I
should be retired right now I shouldn't
have to work
wow
um
Leslie just here's the deal you just got
some hard decisions ahead of you
um I agree with you I would not let my
parents be destitute either
but I'm older I'm in my 40s now I'm not
18. at 18 there's very little you can do
and
um your parents have not asked you hey
how can we make our situation different
they've stolen from you how can we do
you know any insights do you know any
new
tips or tricks or hacks and you could
show them you know Ramsey solution stuff
on how to get out of debt or you could
show them my friend Ken Coleman's stuff
on how to get a job
um
or you could Point them to this show
about how to improve your relationships
and how to improve your mental health
they don't have any interest in that
and so there comes a moment when
you continuing to give them money is
actually disrespectful because you're
participating in you're accelerating
their demise if you will
you see what I'm saying
and so don't participate in their desire
to not be well
also I think like first of all she
barely speaks English and can can't read
or write so also I sympathize with her
in that sense like she can't just pick
up the Dave Ramsey total money makers
okay of course it's hard
like there's like that's what I'm saying
there's no easy path forward here and
I'm not saying that your mom
um
I mean her path is really challenging
it's very very difficult
very difficult and it's lonely and it's
disconcerting and she's lost her her
culture right
um and she's still into this chaos like
I I get all of that it's all hard
the challenge for you is being very
honest with yourself and choosing
reality
you can't heal that for her
she can take steps and she can invite
you in an invitation is much different
than stealing
a plan is much different is more
different than a than a bailout if you
will
and so my heart is broken for her and
with her I totally I empathize with her
all the way and
I know that until she decides I want
this to be different
and here's the deal I worked with
immigrant students my whole career
they were some of the you better get out
of the way dude because there was no
stopping them
no stopping them
and so there is I've seen it over and
over and over and over again
people deciding enough is enough I'm
going to make this different now and I'm
going to take advantage of every
resource and I know poverty's gnarly and
I know I'm gonna have to do something I
don't want to do which is ask for help
and ask for help and ask for help and
ask for help
and I'm gonna have to lean on my kids
not in an impressive way but in a can
you help me out kind of way and I've
just seen it over and over Leslie over
and over
and until your mom comes to that or your
dad comes to that on their own
you can't walk around being their parent
what's funny is that he does very well
financially but they keep their finances
totally separate which is which is a
whole nother situation yeah yeah that's
just them choosing to be uh
dysfunctional like in their relationship
and again there's so many layers here
there's a cultural layer there's the
um educational layer there's the you're
my kid layer there's the I didn't do
anything wrong there's so many layers
here
and every time there's there's a bunch
of layers I want to clear the deck
and write down on a piece of paper what
can I control and what I can I not
control
and what I can control
I'm gonna go for I'm gonna go from there
I'm gonna do those things I'm gonna take
care of those things and you can love
your mom and like I said you can treat
her with dignity and you can treat her
with respect
but you can't make or decide that she's
gonna take care of herself
and you can't make her decide that she
is going to
um have more self-worth than
well I guess this is just all there is
and that you're going to continue your
literature to take from you into
if you will hold you back and in some
shape form or fashion the greatest gift
you could give them is to go be really
successful in school like you said it's
not even about money your dad's got
money they're just not sure they're just
not sharing it
um holding's a mess here
if you were my friend we were sitting
down having nachos I would tell you
write down a piece of paper control what
I can control and let the rest of the
stuff go and just know when it comes to
family when it comes to culture when it
comes to all this mess
letting those things go hurts and it's
painful and you have to grieve it
but just because it hurts doesn't mean
it's wrong
just because it hurts doesn't mean it's
wrong